and i it's only weird like i said for
someone who creates
a weird little distinct category called
religion a category that they don't
understand a category that they can just
like uh count off as superstitious and
stupid and ridiculous although it's a
human universal and it makes them feel
safe that they don't have to understand
this and then it makes them blind to all
these other behaviors that human have
that are ritualized and that could be
really understood if they took a little
bit of time
[Music]
[Music]
this is jonathan pedro
[Music]
welcome to the symbolic world
[Music]
two weeks ago now i'm not even sure time
really flies
some guy that i never heard of who runs
a podcast called decoding the gurus i
guess
uh kind of went after me on twitter at
first he was going after brett weinstein
but then decided i guess to go after me
and uh anyways
he he has the usual kind of you know
dismissive new atheist tone and i was
gonna ignore the guy
but then uh david fuller from rebel
wisdom and uh other people that i
respect you know said that uh this is
important that i should pay attention to
it but really i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna answer too much but
one of the things that this guy uh
attacked me on
is here's one of the tweets he said he's
talking to david fuller and he says here
jonathan pedro saying alex jones
intuition are absolutely correct that
abortion is a human sacrifice for power
and that he would not be at all
surprised if the elites were engaged in
you in ritual sacrifices
and so this was of course his big proof
that i am
uh off that i am off the rails that i'm
some kind of guru or some you know that
i that i'm not worth uh
the attention
and so what i thought is i realize in
reading it that of course this i don't
think this guy could understand what i'm
talking about but i thought it could be
a good opportunity to maybe talk about
sacrifice and maybe help
people understand as much as i can help
you understand what sacrifice is why we
sacrifice and even why human sacrifice
exists and we'll see if in the end
that
that tweet or these comments that i made
about abortion and human sacrifice hold
up once we've gone through the basic uh
the basic ideas one of the issues that
we see with a lot of these kind of new
atheist
types and this kind of new atheist
rhetoric is
that they often act as if religion is
this thing completely set aside in human
behavior and so they create a box called
religion and then they look at what's
going on there and they they uh they
just see it as some kind of aberration
or some kind of
strange behavior that humans are having
and because they don't they don't seem
to want to connect the ritual
let's say religious behavior with other
types of behavior or other types of
regular behavior that humans have then
they find it very strange when other
people do that when i
let's say if i try to explain how
certain behaviors today are akin to
sacrifice i've done this not only in
terms of abortion but in terms of in
terms of war for example i've talked
about uh how we'll get we'll get to it
i've talked about how certain acts in
war are very much akin to human
sacrifice
and so that's the problem it makes it
very difficult to engage with these
types of people because
they're not really trying to understand
why people would sacrifice in the polish
like how did this happen how did humans
start to sacrifice once you start to ask
those questions then all of a sudden you
get larger categories of human behavior
and you can you're able to understand
why it would happen that sacrifice would
be developed and why it is delusional it
really would be a strange delusion to
notice that sacrifice is a human
universal but that today for some reason
we don't do that anymore nobody does
that anymore nobody sacrifices and of
course nobody uh participates in human
sacrifice because you know we're so
evolved that we would never do something
like that but i think that's really the
blindness of not understanding what
sacrifice is what what it's for and so
we're going to look at that and see if
we can figure out on our side
why it is that
sacrifice exists now in order to
understand sacrifice
we really need to go back down into very
very primal categories of what
humans do because
sacrifice is a very very inc it's a
large and encompassing
uh category and several thinkers have
been poking at it and trying to find
solutions at why humans do this
different theory anthropologists or or
religious thinkers have tried to kind of
figure out why it is that humans do this
um and i'm gonna give you my take at it
i don't necessarily think that it's all
encompassing but i do think that it does
encompass quite a bit
of why it is we could get to the get to
this now
we have to go all the way back all the
way to the very bottom of activity of
what a
let's say
what a being with agency does and why it
does what it does and the way that i try
to think about it that brings it all
together is to understand that most of
what we do or possibly everything that a
being with agency does
has two basic goals
um
and it has these goals have to do with
identity they have to do with
the notion of being a being
rather than not right to just existing
as a being
is what we have to come down to in order
to understand sacrifice so we understand
that when
beings act in the world they act for two
major reasons one is to protect the
integrity
of my being
and the others is to expand my being now
expand my being can be something like
adding body adding potential but of
course when we get to conscious beings
and to
higher
level beings we'll see that that also
has to do with something like influence
it can also be a more subtle type of
expansion not necessarily also if not
necessarily just a physical
expansion
but a more subtle one and we also can
understand that expansion of being even
as something as lineage you know as
something like my children as an
extension of my being and that my
children become an extension of me and
so i i can act in a manner to to protect
and to expand the things that are
related to my being we'll see how that
scales up also rather quickly into
higher beings even than humans in terms
of families um
and and different higher beings so we
get to this basic idea so why is it that
i engage with the world you know i
either try to to stop things from
hurting me to prevent things from
destroying the integrity of what i am or
i'm also
either expanding myself or taking things
from the outside and bringing them
inside in order to preserve and to
expand what i am um
so we get now to because we're going to
talk about mostly about sacrifice in
terms of killing animals but there are
other types of sacrifice but we're going
to start with there it makes more sense
so the question is why do we kill things
you know why would humans kill things
and
when you think about it the way that i
explained it you realize that
humans kill things for those reasons
human humans kill things either to
protect themselves so right there's a
predator there's something attacking me
you know there's a there's a mosquito
biting me there's whatever it is that is
attacking me and so i will kill the
thing in order to
to preserve my body or i also kill
things in order to integrate them for
food and to expand my body but i could
also kill things in in in order to
expand my influence and my presence as
well right if there's a predator hunting
on my on on my land and he's killing the
animals that i want to kill then i might
kill that predator in order to have more
access and to expand my my scope my
influence you know my my capacity to
take up
to to to to exist in the world let's say
um so you see that of course it's not
just killing anything we do whether it's
the you know the grass we pull out of
the ground whether it's the wood we cut
will always be about this as well
and you can then scale that up and you
can understand that this is what
this is what happens when you kill
people as well when you kill people you
will do it for those reasons you will do
it either to protect yourself if there's
someone attacking me there's someone
dangerous to me i feel like i have to
kill them in order to
preserve my being or i will also kill in
order to expand to take things from
others to invade other lands you know if
i'm jealous of someone i want to take
what they have or at least want to
eliminate them as rivals for what we're
both looking for so you're going to
start to see that i think that my theory
about sacrifice is ultimately going to
be more encompassing even than gerard's
theory i think so it might be a little
cocky on my on my end to say that uh but
we'll see you'll see that i think that
it it it involved but looking at
renigiral's theory
is is of course
extremely uh useful to help you
understand but first we also can also
understand that
we have to ask ourselves first of all
how we engage with things outside
and then also why would we give things
to others so because sacrifice involves
those two things it involves taking
things from the outside taking you know
either killing things or taking uh
different
things that we've gathered and giving
them to others so why would we do that
and my
my uh
i surmise that the reason why we do that
is the same as why we
kill and take things in the first place
is we do it either
to
you know expand ourself
or to protect ourselves but then the
expanding and protecting happens humans
one of the things that humans realize is
that they also exist at higher levels
they also exist in groups they exist in
higher level beings let's say they don't
only exist they exist in families in
clans and all of this they don't only
exist on their own and so they'll
realize that
as an individual being it will at some
point be worth sacrificing what i have
giving away without what i've gathered
giving away what i've killed in order to
assure
at now a higher level the same thing the
preservation or expansion of the the
higher layer level beings that i
participate in whether it's my clan my
family whether it's a group and then
ultimately whether it's a nation
we'll also see that that sacrifice will
kind of happen
in two directions we could say one going
up or maybe three directions let's say
one going up one going down and then one
maybe going side to side in terms of
gift giving with friends so the one
going up will be something like
you know something
that you see already in the animal world
which is that if a pack of wolves kill
uh kills something then the alpha wolf
will have first access to the food so
there's a sense in which we understand
that when we exist in higher level
structures we have to give a part up
into that structure in order to preserve
the the
preserve the strength of the common
being and so the king gets a part of
what i make you know this is what taxes
our taxes are basically a form of
sacrifice where we offer up to the
higher
being which is the king or the state or
something which is above us in order to
preserve our existence to expand
our influence now this you'll realize
that once
once humans realize that this works
that if i give a part of what i have
up
towards
towards a higher level being my family
my team my clan or whatever that this
can also be ritualized and can be given
up to the reason why we exist in the
first place so this is what giving
giving things to a god is it's actually
a more economic way of all of us binding
together and giving a part of what we
have up
up towards the ideal of why we exist
together so that it that
that ideal will then come back down and
will let's say
will hold us together in a way that that
binds us but we'll see a little more
about that as we go first i want to look
a little more at
gerard's theory now gerard's theory
is wonderful because he kind of gets
what i'm saying and he realizes
that in order for groups to exist
together they have to care for the same
things
and this is actually the very existence
of an of a group i mentioned this before
in order for a group to exist we have to
have one purpose or one ideal any group
whether it's
you know a group of people working on a
prototype in a company whether it's a
baseball team or whatever sports team or
there is something there is something we
care about all of us care about
that
binds us towards that care binds us to
that thing now you can imagine that
there are multiple things that can do
that and there can also be a hierarchy
of things
so we we let's say we care about certain
things and then at a lower levels we
also care about secondary goods as well
so we can understand that
in a group
certain things become valuable certain
resources you know
women children all these things become
valuable and then because we all care
for the same things then
it binds us together but it creates of
course a problem because when we care
for the same things the resources are
limited the possibility of accessing
these things that we care about are
limited as well so what will happen
is that will create rivalry and
competition within the group and so the
very thing that binds us will create
competition and rivalry and so this is a
serious problem because what it can do
is it can lead to all-out conflict where
everybody starts ripping each other
apart through through cycles of revenge
you know i i'm jealous of my neighbor so
i kill him to take his wife or to take
his stuff but then his family notice see
that i did that then they take revenge
on me and so you have these eternal
cycles of revenge and so we have to find
ways
to
con continue to cohere or else groups
will just fall
fall apart and cease to exist
and this will happen through ritualized
behavior and so just like
you know just like a a dog will
ritualize a conflict in order to avoid
killing each other they will ritualize
aggression ritualize submission and then
they'll create a ritualized encounter in
order to avoid the cost of it boiling
down all the way into all behavior
for the same reasons humans also do that
it's there's nothing weird even for an
atheist to understand that ritualized
behavior is a is a way in which to avoid
the cost of a certain
social dynamic and to to bring it higher
into bring it up to its pattern in a
manner in which it will then let's say
order reality and not be as costly in
the at the at the bottom of things um
so what gerard noticed is that what
people would tend to do
is that they would
take all the problems in the tribe all
of the things that were
breaking the tribe apart and they would
end up
focusing it
finding someone who was weak who was
diseased or someone who
just didn't fit in sometimes it would
actually be a stranger like an enemy
prisoner someone who's not part of the
group or is almost not part of the group
and then they would say well it's
because of that person
because of this person that the group
isn't going together right it's a
scapegoat behavior so they would they
would put all the blame on the person
the the scapegoat they would say that
it's this person's fault that i'm not
able that we are not able to reach what
it is we care about because they they
are in the way they're not they're not
they're oddly not buying they're not
binding the group they're not
participating in the man in which the
group binds together they would put all
the blame on that person they would kill
that person and then it would rebind
them towards what it is that they cared
about they would it would create a kind
of ecstasy and a um
it would create a kind of an ecstasy and
a kind of moment where the group would
feel in acting together in violence
towards the scapegoat that they
recognize each other
as one they recognize each other as
being something that exists in the world
um this is this is um
this is difficult to understand for
people who think that groups just exist
groups don't just exist beings don't
just exist they need something to bind
them together for them to exist and that
has a mechanism and if you don't
understand it then there's a lot of
stuff about religion that you will never
understand because you somehow think
that people just exist together without
ways to bind in order for them to to to
to move towards common uh goals and
common things that they care about um
so what you would you realize is that
this gerard's theory works very with
perfectly with my idea that basically
the way in which a group acts will be a
way in
to act in order to bind themselves has
to do with identity
in
in binding and creating a hierarchy and
identifying an outside right we take
something on the edge we take something
strange we we kill it we basically cast
it out
and then that
ejects that which is not good that which
is outside of us in a ritual way and it
binds us together towards something
um and so you can do that of course you
can understand that this is already what
happens in the very existence of the
group in the patterning of attention
this is what is already happening it is
in order you know i've mentioned this
before let's say in order for a
basketball team to exist as a basketball
team it has to be able to sacrifice it
has to be able to
focus its attention on a common goal
to identify the things that are the
obstacles to which for to reach that
goal and then to eliminate them and so
if there's a bad player on the team they
will get rid of the bad player if
there's bad behavior on the team then
they will eliminate behavior and so you
realize that actually
sacrifice
is the very way in which things exist
it's for anything to exist it has to
sacrifice some aspect of its
idiosyncrasy in order for it to exist
together and this is going to sound
weird for people to understand but in
order for you to understand the
existence of objects of of any being you
realize that the pattern of sacrifice is
embedded in the very existence of all
objects because
even though i recognize this as being a
cup it has indefinite idiosyncrasy in it
which is which could make it not a cup
that is not participating in his cupness
you could say but in order for me to
recognize it as a cup i have to
sacrifice the idiosyncrasy even in my
attention i have to i have to not pay
attention to the things that are
idiosyncratic in the object so that i
can experience it and participate it in
it in a way that is to its purpose in
the way in which it is to the reason why
i care about this thing in the first
place which is that i use it to drink
out of
um
now of course there are ways to play
with this there
this isn't there are ways in which
sometimes a little bit of of
of idiosyncrasy is part of the pattern
we've talked about this in other videos
i won't go into it right now but
as a basic pattern we have to understand
that that is how things exist through
sacrificing idiosyncrasy and also
let's say the the different aspects of
the group have to give aspects of
themselves up in order to participate in
their higher being
all right so it's a good way to
understand emergence in general all
right so we understand that this is the
basic idea of how gerard works and you
can understand it
as a good way
of understanding how all things exist
and the idea is that mimetics sacrifice
the way that gerard defines it is useful
but i think that
gerard really focuses on the scapegoat
part but what you realize is that there
are many types of sacrifices which will
participate in things existing and they
don't all fit with the notion of mimetic
sacrifice you can understand like i've
said the the idea of giving up right the
idea of giving up towards our identity
is not exactly the same as memetic
sacrifice so we we get taxes is the best
way to understand sacrifice up the
hierarchy towards toward higher level
beings um but there's also a way in
which we
sacrifice down in which the higher level
beings will also give part of itself
down to the lower beings i've mentioned
this before
you see that of course in the idea of
the emperor giving bread to the masses
you know you see that also in the sense
of let's say the state offering uh
services to the people and so taking
that which has which is how it has
received but also not just using it for
its own self-existence it has to give
back down towards the group so imagine a
king for example that takes taxes and
then the king doesn't do anything for
the people at some point they're going
to kill the king at some point they're
going to get rid of him but if the king
offers protection and offers that which
i talked about in the outset which is to
maintain the identity of the group to
maintain it towards a purpose that the
group cares about then people will
accept to give up to the higher being in
order to receive back down a kind of
order a kind of structure
and protection from the outside and so
but the king has to offer that he has to
sacrifice back down towards the group in
order for the so this is the type of
exchange that happens um
so you can see that often in the uh
ritualized sacrifices you'll see that
this is happening at the same time where
someone will take an animal that is
usually you know a good animal like the
best animal something unblemished or
something and they will give up
towards
the god that binds the group together
but then that will already immediately
come back down on them and then they
will eat the meat of the sacrifice and
so we give up and then we receive at the
same time and this might seem weird for
people because they think you know it's
like why are you giving it up to god why
don't you just eat the animal
but we have to understand that ritual
behavior is a way to bind us towards a
common purpose and towards the common
reason why we exist together and so when
we know that everybody is doing this
everybody is offering up
a sacrifice to the thing that binds us
together to the identity that binds us
together and then ritually we then all
engage in the bounty that that offers us
then we are binding each other to
binding together as a community so this
is this is i know people are now i know
atheists are going to freak out they're
going to be like what this doesn't make
any sense but you have to understand it
fractally you have to understand it this
is what we do all the time right we
imagine a family you you invite your
family over for dinner and then
everybody brings up a meal everybody
brings some food everybody brings a dish
and then we all
put it together towards the thing that
binds us together which is that we are a
family and we exist together with a
common care and a common identity and a
common purpose and then as we all put
that together and we offer it up to the
to our family then it comes back down
and we sit at a table and then we
celebrate what are we celebrating we're
celebrating our family we're celebrating
the thing that binds us together and so
we we offer up food we sit together at a
table and then we eat together and you
say well why don't you just sit at home
and just eat just take food and eat it
you know why would you do something like
that and
this is where people don't like i said
people are ignorant of why it is that
humans exist together in the first place
and so ritual sacrifice that is offered
up to a god is one level higher than the
type of behavior that you engage with
when you are
getting together
as a family for thanksgiving and
everybody bringing some food
and then eating together you know and
there's a and it's and it's important
because if you don't eat the food
then your family is it's a it will be an
image of your family not being together
by the way i hope you know that right if
your aunt brings some food and nobody
eats the food that the one on brings
then that will uh reflect the manner in
which her sacrifice is not accepted her
sacrifice is rejected and that she is
not not really bound together in the
proper way and you know that that's true
by the way if you have a family that you
actually care about you realize that
this is something you have to think
about um
and so
you can see that so you can see
different versions of this you can
realize that
the there are different types of ways in
which this happens so for example
ritualized manners in which you give
towards authorities in order to avoid
the problems the best way to understand
it is of course the tribute because you
imagine that
a king comes into your land he's not
really your king yet and he basically
demands tribute he says give me this
amount every year
and why is he saying that
it's a racket right he's saying that
because he's it's protection money he's
saying pay me this this amount every
year
and if you don't then i will come and i
will pillage your land and i will rape
your women and i will take your children
and so the ritualization of the behavior
will avoid the cost of it at the ground
it will avoid the king having to have
his soldiers die it will avoid the
people having their people died and
killed and raped and it will become a
ritualized manner in which we sacrifice
one part of what we have up to this
higher level
authority that is coming to us in order
to in order to to
to impose its authority on it so this is
not good or bad guys this is not about
sacrificing is good sacrificing is bad
it's just about how the world works this
is how the world works and you can't get
away from it this is this is just the
manner in which you in which in which it
works um so it helps you really see the
double-sidedness of of all of these
authorities of all civilization of all
of the manner in which uh authority
structures exist are always double-sided
you can see the positive aspect in which
you know the idea that the king will
cover you and will protect you or the
state will cover you and will protect
you in order to
in order to hold your identity together
but you can also see it how it can
become tyrannical and it can be uh
basically protection money
that you have to pay or else they're
going to put you in jail so pay your
taxes or else you go to jail even if you
don't believe at some point authority
becomes inescapable in the world um
all right and so
we have to then understand that the the
word the dif
direct relationship if you see that
there's a relationship between
human sacrifice
and war
you know
you can see that
when you fight a war
once again people think that identities
exist
just just exist they don't just exist
i have an identity i have a city i have
a clan i have things a group of people
that i identify as having one identity
and now all of a sudden that group that
i identify as one
is threatened
by a group on the outside now why do i
care why don't i just give in and cease
to exist and become part of that other
group
because i care about these things i care
because also if i am taken over by
another group i will lose
the the value of what binds me together
i'll become a slave for the other group
i'll become a lower part of the the
group that's attacking me and so i want
to preserve my
identity i want to preserve the identity
of my group and so i understand in war
that
i am willing because i don't know what's
going to happen right if i am if i am a
group and i'm attacking another group in
order to expand my identity expand my
power expand my influence expand my
glory
i don't even know i don't know what's
going to happen
but i
i am betting
on the future that i am willing to
sacrifice members of my group
in order to reach that goal that i care
about
and the same goes for the protective
side i'm being attacked by another group
why don't we just scatter why don't we
just run away why don't we just why
don't we just you know cease to exist
and i'm like no i want to continue to
exist and i am willing to sacrifice
members of my group i'm willing to kill
them for this higher purpose in order to
continue to exist as a group and so
there's a com there's a direct
relationship
between
war and human sacrifice and we
understand it if you look at the
different rituals that happen in the
manner in which human sacrifice was
practiced in different civilizations you
will really you will realize that that
is the case you will realize in the
things that we
recognize more let's say more directly
as being human sacrifice
which is the notion of uh ritually
killing someone in a in a very formal
way that it is just a way to avoid the
cost
of of the the normal protection and
let's say expansion of my identity and
so
that is why for example you can
understand that
let's say when the romans took over gaul
took over a certain amount of of
of the country they realized that they
also don't want to totally decimate
the other people and take over their
land there's something
it's not even to their advantage to do
that because those are resources that
they that they want to use
so in order to mark their authority in
order to stop the killing one of the
things that they will do is that they
would they would sacrifice their enemies
so they would take some people some some
of the leaders or they would take a
certain amount of people from the from
the enemy group and they would ritually
kill them
in order to mark
their
the way the man in which they ruled that
group in order to mark the expansion of
their authority to declare it to say we
have
we have taken over this this land we
have taken over these people we've taken
over this power and you see that this
happens in many uh
many uh civilizations where the killing
of a slave for example or the killing of
an enemy a captured enemy is part of the
behavior because they want to mark
the their power on the other but they
also want to limit the cost they don't
want to just slaughter everybody um
and this is real politic guys like i'm
not i'm not skimming skimping at how the
world works um
but what you realize is that
sacrifice is inevitable you know
that
it is part of identity itself and once
you realize this you realize that it
also explains a lot of other types of
sacrifices which is for example the
sacrifice of food and so sometimes we it
doesn't have to always have to be meat
it could be grain it could be all kinds
of things the pouring out of libations
all these types of sacrifices will be
ritualized ways of marking a giving up
either up towards the the higher purpose
of the group in order for all of us to
recognize that we are bound to this to
this um it's about attention that we are
bound to this purpose or down sometimes
you also give down to
to your fallen ones you know this idea
of pouring one out for the lost for the
lost ones where you pour out a drink on
the ground in order to commemorate the
dead
you can understand that this is also a
manner in which to preserve the memory
of our group to preserve the idea that
we are together by remembering those
that are fallen and creating once again
this sense of cohesion not just in space
but also in time with the people that
were that preceded us and so giving out
food to the dead is a manner in which we
can remain bound to them through the all
through the sacrifice of something that
is precious to us all right
all right so i'm not going through all
of it but hopefully you're starting to
see how this is how this works and how
why it is that sacrifice is part of of
human reality
in the the ritualized sacrifice you end
up having different types of sacrifices
you can imagine that
in terms of especially in terms of human
sacrifice you can imagine that there is
the scapegoat sacrifice that i talked
about but that there's also like the
sacrifice to found a city so you realize
that a lot of civilizations participate
in human sacrifices in order to found
cities in order also to found houses so
you find
under houses the under posts let's say
that hold up houses you will find human
remains of people that were killed or
sacrificed and put under the house of in
order to hold the house up so of course
we're all materialists we're all we're
all scientists and so we think that
that's superstitious why would you kill
someone
and put them under the post of a house
to hold up the house and this is of
course where
we struggle to understand different
types of causality we don't understand
that if you make if you put something
precious
as the foundation of your home if you
sacrifice something precious in order to
bind
even a building together even uh even
even a family together then that will
hold it and it will it will hold it not
through weird superstitious means it
will hold it through attention it will
hold it through the knowing of
of and there's it can become quite
subtle but nonetheless there's even if
just the person that does something like
that understand what they what they paid
the price that they're paying in order
to exist together in a home in a house
in order for things to to bind together
then they will do it now
i'm not trying to defend human sacrifice
i obviously do not
do not believe in human sacrifice i'm a
christian i think that the the story of
christ has solved the problem of human
sacrifice because there is something
itchy about it and we realize that
we realize uh as we look at how it
develops and moves towards animal
sacrifice and then moves ultimately
towards
more subtle forms of sacrifice that
there's a refining of the sacrifice
system but to simply deny it and think
that it's completely it makes absolutely
no sense and not to understand that
why it is that why it exists is also
being extremely naive and not
understanding how it works um
and so you can understand how people
would sacrifice things in order to get
from higher authorities and that would
be ritualized into the sacrifice to
a god a sacrifice to a god in the sense
of the god as the principality as the
top of what it is that binds us together
and so just to to go back over what we
talked about just in terms of going back
over the idea that there are different
levels of ritualization in killing all
killing is is to a certain extent
ritualized because it is done with a
purpose and therefore has to be done
towards that purpose but there are
different levels of ritualizations of
course
uh in killing
and you can understand how this is what
happens in the animal kingdom itself
where
it's and even you can realize that it's
not just even about killing sometimes
you don't even kill sometimes you can
create the pattern of sacrifice in a
manner which is dedication and so you
see that in um
in scripture for example where people
would dedicate themselves and uh
to the temple for example you see that
in in scripture where you know someone
is given to god and that person lives in
the temple and then becomes a servant of
the temple the idea that uh you know you
would
give up your your men toward to be in
the army and so you give up at least one
of your sons will become a priest for
example these are ways in which we
understand that
when we talk about even human sacrifice
it doesn't necessarily mean that someone
has to die but it means that
that we give up
someone to a higher good
and then that binds us together so the
idea of
let's say you know this idea in catholic
countries where every family kind of had
to have one
member of their family uh become a
priest let's say was this kind of giving
up towards a higher purpose um but of
course you see that
even just an animal in animal uh
in animal behavior where
an animal is killed and then the best
part of that killed animal will be given
up towards the the alpha male let's say
um we talked about scapegoat sacrifices
and we have this idea for example in
scripture that the firstborn is
dedicated to god and you can understand
how in some cultures this type of
thinking would lead to actually killing
your
firstborn which seems crazy to us but we
have a sense in which the firstborn has
to kind of embody in a way the highest
ideal of our family
and i know that this is gonna sound
weird but there's a sense in which the
best part is given up towards the the
the the ideal and so that's where you
can see why
that's where you can understand also why
there is that in in war where we have
the sense in which we give up our best
men in order for them to to fight and to
die
for the cause of our nation this is
there's very little difference between
the two it's just that one is more
ritualized let's say than the other
and will usually also lead to less
killing because
in a war there is ritualization but it
can become very messy and you and the
number of people that die and then under
people the number of people that end up
getting sacrificed for the unity of our
group is much larger than than in human
sacrifice so you can understand why in
human sacrifice there was a way in which
this was a way to have an economic way
of killing in order to attain the goal
that something like war ends up
attaining um
all right and so you can understand how
in different cultures then there would
be there would also be
initiation sacrifices and so
there are many examples of that for
example the spartans
when the the spartan
citizens reached a certain age of
initiation one of the things that they
would do is there would be a certain
amount of time in which they were
it was fair game to kill
any servant in the land and so the
spartans would go out and they would
murder as many serfs and as many
as many slaves as they could in order to
mark
their capacity
to be a spartan it was an initiation
sacrifice we see that of course in
different
gang initiations and the legends of
gang's initiation some of them are maybe
not actually embodied but the stories of
them still kind of imbibe our culture
you know you have this idea that if
you're a member of the aryan brotherhood
or whatever you have to kill a rival
in order to participate in order to be a
member sometimes you don't necessarily
have to kill to be a member but if you
do kill a rival gang member or if you
kill someone from another gang or if you
even kill an innocent person then that
will make you go up in the hierarchy
that it becomes a form of marking the
outside by killing that which is outside
or eliminating something which is weak
inside the group a rival that you're
able to beat in order to make the group
stronger and to bind you together
and there's also a manner in which
acting in that scandalous way this is
something that you see in mimetic in
mimetic sacrifice is that there's
something about doing something horrible
like killing another human being that
you recognize
as being a mirror of you right you
humans are different from animals
because you see in their face a mirror
of yourself and so the idea that to
go into something as scandalous as
killing another human being and doing it
as a group or doing it for a group
becomes the ultimate marker of
participating in a scandal
by which we exist together this is of
course especially true in criminal
organizations where the idea that if
you're willing to kill someone in order
to be part of this group then we can
trust your
we can trust the fact that you care
about
our group more than anything else that
this is what you you completely uh care
about and so killing becomes a very
powerful tool for any kind of criminal
syndicate it it offers all kinds of
solutions to the problem of existing in
an illegitimate and uh and a uh
in something which is illegal and
something which is criminal is that if
you get people to kill others or you
make it part of the way in which you
scale up the hierarchy of a criminal
organization then you are
not only participating in a scandalous
act together but you are you are also
making them dependent on you because you
know that they killed someone and that
this binds them to you in ways that are
more than one let's say you know by part
by knowing about this person's scandal
then they also become
they owe you because you could always
denounce them you know you you you share
something together which is the
knowledge that you've all killed someone
together that you've all killed someone
so these are all ways in which uh
initiation sacrifices are a way of
participating in human sacrifice that
that works like it actually works in
order to bind a group together it's
horrible uh but it works
and so you realize that in the gospel of
saint john we have actually
a
you act you actually have a uh a
very short definition of what it is that
sacrifice is human sacrifice especially
and you have it when uh
when the the sanhedrin are questioning
or wondering what to do about this jesus
fellow
and because they can see that jesus is
causing problems you know through the
the
turning over of the the tables in the
temple through the resurrection of
lazarus he's attracting a lot of
attention to himself to the jews they're
scared of the romans they're scared
about also the people what the people
are seeing and how it's
it's it's destabilizing their group and
so you know the
one of the members of the sanhuita says
you do not realize that it is better for
you that one man die for the people
than that the whole nation perish
and so the idea of being able to
eliminate one person
you know by
for by the sanhedrin killing this one
person they would be one marking
their allegiance to rome by saying we're
denouncing a traitor
right they're also binding themselves
together by participating and killing
this ultimately innocent person
all of this is happening at the same
time they realize that by doing this
then they will bind themselves together
and so in this case of course you
realize that
in many civilizations this type of
function
when you realize that until very
recently the executions were always
public so the public execution is a way
is another form of human sacrifice where
we kill someone in public we make sure
everybody sees that and we realize that
by doing that we are going to mark the
limit of behavior in our society in a
very dramatic and and uh and powerful
way
of course political assassinations are
that as well we realize that if i can
just kill this member of this enemy team
this enemy group of this enemy nation if
i can just kill bin laden then there
will be less bloodshed so i will we will
bind together to kill this one person in
order to bind to to preserve the
identity of our group because we realize
that if we do that then we don't have to
go to war or the war that we are having
with the other people is going to be
diminished by killing the the these few
people let's say
and this is going to be
very controversial
but there is a manner in which the the
watching of george floyd dying the
killing of george floyd
ended up being something like a human
sacrifice it ended up being something
like someone dying
and then binding care together and
trying to create a social
cohesion under
the death of one person so
george floyd gets killed and then people
massive people all over the world
demonstrate in the street for days and
days and weeks cities you know there's a
sense in which there's this catharsis
which happens
that is exactly the type of catharsis
that would happen in any
in any kind of human sacrifice but
strangely enough it's it's it's actually
closer to the christian
version of of human sacrifice because
there is a serious problem with
sacrifice you know and what it does
because
it is nonetheless the ritual there's
something which when we look into the
face of another human being
and we see that mirror
there's something about
killing someone else which is very
different like i said from killing an
animal and so there's a manner in which
seems like in human culture there was
something bubbling there was something
bubbling up
to
help us understand that there's
something off about the manner in which
we we do that there's something in the
the the reflection of myself and the
other which makes this type of behavior
something unacceptable and this is of
course what ultimately leads to this is
what why rene jihad says that the fact
that in the story of jesus christ we see
the ritual
scapegoat sacrifice from the point of
view of the one who is sacrificed that
it actually
collapses and completely resolves in a
manner the problem and the reality of
the scapegoat sacrifice because
the victim
of scapegoat sacrificing is often
innocent
because
the problem of desire is there in the
group and so we the fact that we throw
all our the sins of the group onto one
person
is of course too much for that person to
bear and this is this is a it's a it's
somewhat like a momentary
binding but it's a cycle like this
constant cycle of
you have to keep doing that over and
over in order to refresh and to rebind
you together now in the christian story
we have a sense in which as we
take the place
of the sacrificed one as we we take the
position of the sacrificed one then it
it is actually revealing the mechanism
of the scapegoat sacrifice and in a way
heals it or
recast it in a different manner
and it also i've talked about this
before it actually exposes
a secret about reality which is that the
true manner in which
things bind together and hold together
is through self-sacrifice
it is not through sacrificing other
things although it works but ultimately
we realize that it is
if i want my family to bind together i
have to sacrifice my idiosyncrasies to
the common goal i have to give myself to
the love that exists in my family and
that is the proper way for a family to
exist
i could find a
a black sheep in the family we could
have one of the the chil one of our many
children in the in the the family
represents the black sheep they're
always to blame it's always their fault
it's always they're the ones who are
responsible for all our woes and it
works right it actually will bind it
together but it will leave this residue
this dark residue on the outside and
what that does is it creates the cycle
where it has to we have to keep this
black
sheep there or recast it into someone
else in order for the group to continue
to exist what what the christian story
reveals is that
the proper way the best way for a group
to exist is that if we all
if we all sacrifice ourselves towards
the love that we have together let's say
in a family then that will be the proper
way for the group to exist and it will
be a a more
a stronger way and a a healthier way for
a group to bind together so what we see
in the george floyd thing is
a weird version of this position where
now the victim
is elevated and now the victim becomes
that which binds people towards a common
purpose and is policy making
it actually leads policy
you know laws were changed budgets were
changed things were realigned in the
wake of people watching george floyd and
george floyd die and so if you don't
think that that's a kind of human
sacrifice i don't know what to tell you
because it worked it i mean it worked in
the sense that it created one person
dying
changed laws all over the united states
so you can bicker and tell me that i'm
i'm being i'm exaggerating and saying
that it's it was it's participating in
the pattern of human sacrifice
but then why is it changing things why
is it actually rebinding society towards
different purposes how did it do that if
it doesn't if it's not effective if
if one person dying
doesn't can't change the way society or
redirect or rebind or recast society i
don't know what to tell you once you
also start to see it this way you
realize that the modern geopolitical
world is based on
several sacrifices but two very large
human sacrifices
and the stability of the modern world
is based on
two sacrifices one which was the
holocaust which even uses
language of sacrifice we continue to say
the holocaust in and i'm sure that our
atheist friends
won't dare use in other words be besides
holocaust
why because you don't get to decide
whether or not it works that way and so
the the the the holocaust functions as
a rebinding of society where living in
that
in the in the fact of that sacrifice i'm
not justif when it's not about
justifying it it's about what it does
what effect it had
and so we constantly remember we
remember the holocaust has become part
of the narrative which holds the western
world together that we did this
remembering that we did this that the
that the west did this that that that
some people were willing to go this far
as to kill all these innocents
and we we and it it
created international law it created all
these things that bind us but there's
another one too and which is it's of
course hiroshima and nagasaki
it's a classic example of human
sacrifice because
the united states calculated they don't
know what's going to happen the united
states don't know the future they can't
completely tell the future
but they realize that
if we kill these innocent people if we
destroy entire cities
then we make a bet
that it will rebind us together at a
higher level that it will
stop the war
i mean that is exactly what ritualized
sacrifice is
we we calculate that if we engage in
this one ritual act of slaughtering
innocents
thousands and thousands and tens of
thousands of innocents
then it will heal us and we will and
will rebind our society now i don't
i am scandalized by by
by both of these
but i can i'm not as stupid enough i'm
smart enough to realize that it worked
that it happened that
that it and it participates exactly in
the pattern of of human sacrifice that
was
that would that happen thousands of
years ago there's no difference
in terms of the pattern there's only a
difference if you want to create a weird
you know autonomous category called
religion
but if you don't then you realize that
it works
and that it happened
and so
first of all
let's look then at abortion what is
abortion abortion is exactly the same
thing abortion is exactly that
someone someone gets pregnant
and now they have something that they
care about they have a purpose they have
something which they think is important
and which binds their being towards a
purpose
and all of a sudden
something gets in the way
this this this this burgeoning human in
them gets in the way
and they don't know what the future how
could you know the future you don't know
what's going to happen
but they make a bet
and they identify
the the fetus they identify the child in
their body as the cause of why they're
not going to be able to reach their goal
they identified as something which is
the reason it's the scapegoat it's
exactly what a scapegoat sacrifice is
they're they're saying it's that thing's
fault it's that person's fault
and they dehumanize the the fetus like
it's that it's
[Music]
it's the fetus's fault that i'm not
going to be able to accomplish my
purpose and my goal and so i will
sacrifice it to my purpose
and once i get rid of that of the reason
why i can't reach my purpose then i'm
rebound towards the purpose which i had
in the first place and so
i don't know what to say
i mean
i don't know what to say besides that
it participates in the same pattern it's
just it's just a dif it's not
re understood as religious it doesn't
matter
but it nonetheless participates in the
same pattern and so
let's get to the second part of the
tweet that i said that i wouldn't be
surprised if elites engage in ritualized
human sacrifice now i'm not saying that
they do i don't know if they do i'm
saying i wouldn't be surprised if they
did
and why would i not be surprised if they
did
because i look around me and i see that
criminal syndicates
use killing as initiation methods
they've used it for thousands of years
whether it's the spartans or whether
it's the hells angels they use killing
as initiation mechanisms and and i'm not
saying that all the elites function as
criminal syndicates but there are
certainly some elites that function as
criminal syndicates and to the extent
that they function
as criminal organizations and syndicates
and they use the same patterns and
structures as as the mob or the mafia or
or other criminal syndicates then why
would i be surprised that they used that
they would use killing as initiation
sacrifices i mean
i don't know if they do but i wouldn't
be surprised if they did because it's a
human universal and you see it in
civilizations
that date thousands of years ago and you
see it in the streets of big cities
today and so i don't i don't see why
that's weird and i it's only weird like
i said for someone who creates
weird little distinct category called
religion a category that they don't
understand a category that they can just
like uh count off as superstitious and
stupid and ridiculous although it's a
human universal and it makes them feel
safe that they don't have to understand
this and then it makes them blind to all
these other behaviors that human have
that are ritualized and that could be
really understood if they took a little
bit of time to understand uh to
understand what religious what they call
religious uh behaviors are
and so hopefully this was scandalous
enough for you
and uh but helpful also to understand
that this isn't
there's no taboos we're not we're not
going to pretend
you know
we need to understand why humans do
certain things and if we can understand
it then it will help us also understand
the best version of that because
i believe the christian story is the
best version of that i believe the true
sacrifice is self-sacrifice
and
and i can explain why and i can tell you
why and i can see it as the the
culmination and the reversal of this
whole pattern of sacrifice
but if you don't try to understand it
and you can't tell me why you think
self-sacrifice
and you believe it for some amorphous
strange reason that nobody understands
why it why it is the most important then
before you know it you're going to be
calling for the death of
who knows what scapegoat that you're
going to find whether right now we can
kind of see it coming up again where you
know facebook has allowed us to wish for
the death of people of a certain nation
and we just do that without
realizing that once again and whether
whether they are responsible or not
responsible you know like i i want i
don't certainly don't want to defend
what's what they're doing right now but
but nonetheless it's still participating
in this pattern
that we think that
we are we are somehow
anyways
it's good to try to understand what
sacrifice is and it was helpful
to uh to understand a lot of symbolic
behavior so hopefully this has been
useful
and um and yeah so we'll talk to you
very soon
as you know the symbolic world is not
just a bunch of videos on youtube we are
also a podcast which you can find on
your uh usual podcast platform but we
also have a website with a blog and
several very interesting articles by
very intelligent people that have been
thinking about symbolism on all kinds of
subjects we also have a clips channel a
facebook group you know there's a whole
lot of ways that you can get more
involved in the exploration and the
discussion of symbolism don't forget
that my brother matsuya wrote a book
called the language of creation which is
a very powerful synthesis of a lot of
the ideas that explore and so please go
ahead and explore this world you can
also participate by you know buying
things that i've designed t-shirts with
different designs on them and you can
also support this podcast and these
videos through paypal or through patreon
everybody who supports me has access to
an extra video a month and there are
also all kinds of other goodies and
tiers that you can get involved with so
everybody thank you again and thank you
for your support